if you weren't sharing your music with
people what do you think that you would
be doing what's like another a thing
thing you would do in life it sounds
really odd you can think a bit odd okay
I can't wait I I used to always want to
be a fishmonger wait what
what the hell is that like I remember
like in whenever I go to a supermarket
and I see like raw people buy the raw
fish I just love it I just I think it
looks so cool
you like I like fishing I love fishing
although do you ever get sick like on
the boat oh no I just sit by a pond
that's the kind I need yeah I've gone
deep sea and it just ends with me all
over the side of it yeah though I could
do that wait but like the fish monger
yeah like yeah and I could have a little
shop that sells fish they just have
their fish wrapped in parchment paper
ready to go it's all nice it's all on
ice fishes on Ice okay I have stinky
hands though that's the only problem
yeah yeah yeah but even yeah yeah you
just smelled it
he did that or I'd probably be a florist
I'm I love flowers I think I could be a
floor I love no actually I take that
back I'm not great at it I just love it
yeah but I read this book that tells you
like the meaning of flowers because in
Victorian times like people couldn't
talk especially the opposite sex so
they'd like communicate through flowers
oh very much you know your birth flower
I don't mine's lily of the valley I have
it literally the valley is one of my
favorite flowers do you know the story
behind it like the tears and they like
when or the blood of the and it went
down I mean it's I'm going to send you
this whole book yes and and the lilies
came up from the tears of oh it's
beautiful oh my gosh I love that
they eat this I love it
I'm together but I just we could sell it
yeah but I do it I'm very like into it I
send the meaning of each flower when I
send the flower they're all meaningful
totally you can there's one for every
emotion and I just yeah I love it when
someone sends me flowers it's just the
greatest gift so next time somebody asks
you the question lead with florist yeah
I was like that sounds interesting
um but whatever dream your dream fish
and flowers yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]